so seeing that we're all connected with
social media these days and you work on
kevin davis's man in a box yep you then
meet some fellow actors on facebook yeah
so while there's been um
you know there's been some great you
know connections through man in a box
and there's been a lot of like kind of
ironic things um
so i met michael and i met warren and i
also met michelle
um all three of
them are actually going to be in my film
capsized um so i didn't get to work with
them directly um because i was the
editor for man in a box but that is how
i met them um and so
you know we developed friendships and um
so
it's interesting that i think you know
networking once upon a time was you know
if you go to the right go to the right
party go to the right meet up you know
you're going to meet all these people
and now a lot of that's happening
virtually so it's happening through
these social networks so you know that's
kind of the good you know the good
aspect of social networking
um
but you know
it's a small world i mean
the the connections
um
you know you think man of the box was
filmed out in philadelphia and these
actors are from new york um and just you
know just the other day
my music composer
tells me you know they went out to
dinner with this guy jerry
and he's like yeah yeah jerry cunningham
i think you know him i said
yeah he's the assistant director for man
in a box
i'm like wait how did you guys meet him
you know i'm like i'm friends with him
on facebook too um and so that was you
know kind of kind of humorous and then
uh there was another interesting
connection for you know our film which
is when i was casting for capsized
there's a role that we cast
and just you know we did auditions and
it turns out that the guy we cast
actually was in the commercial with
michael with jay-z oh my god and i was
like i was like wait wait
yeah cause once i cast him he went on my
website and he's like he goes he goes
you're gonna laugh he goes um i actually
know
michael he's like we work together out
in new york so it's kind of funny i mean
so i mean i have to give a lot of credit
to kevin for giving me the opportunity
to edit man in a box because
i mean so many of these connections that
are now part of my new film
came from you know this whole experience
that we've all shared with a man in a
box so it's pretty cool
and so by
people seeing the film they might see
yours and then vice versa oh yeah
absolutely so it's a stall yeah
and yeah that's and that's the great
thing about this medium that's the great
thing about film is it is in the end of
the day it's all just you know it's a
great collaborative effort um and you
don't know which opportunity uh which
project you work on is going to be the
one that gets you noticed for your
respective field
and it could come from not even your own
work it could come from you know one of
your colleagues work
somebody might see a film one day that
michael uh is in and they may say you
know hey what are these other movies
that that he did with you know some of
these guys and just kind of goes goes
from there